Elizabeth the update us we're looking at
some of these live pictures coming
through update us on the latest
developments well the fatalist County
Police Chief Jon Belmar said that police
have made at least 29 arrest tonight in
at least 12 buildings are on fire in
Ferguson there was no serious injuries
amongst police officers but there were
at least 150 shots of inspired by
protesters and again this is according
to st. Louis County Police she said that
he's disappointed that we didn't see
more peaceful protest here tonight and
actually the violence tonight is a lot
worse than the worst nights back in
August right after the Michael Brown
shooting and Elizabeth what does
President Obama been saying so far about
this situation of course this goes back
to August but we're witnessing this
resurgence in violence overnight well I
know President Obama urged for peace
before tonight I've been on the ground
all night so I haven't been able to see
his remarks like i said i'm hearing
ferguson we got the news that the grand
jury chose not to indict officer Darren
Wilson shortly after eight o'clock
central time tonight I guess it's no
this morning and the crowds in front of
the Ferguson Police Department had a
strong reaction right away police say
that protesters threw rocks right away
at police once the verdict was non
verdict actually was announced and from
that there was just a lot of anger all
night fires broken windows even some
looting hold on the main strip by the
Ferguson Police Department vaca and west
florissant which is near where the
shooting took place in August Elizabeth
thank you very much for joining us i get
to get the perspective on the ground
elizabeth campbell bloomberg reporter in
Ferguson Missouri